virus numbers as you just saw they are
dropping here and across the country but
medical experts are still worried about
the next few months a main reason
spring break could cause another surge
in cases
officials in south florida are trying to
crack down on those wild parties
one popular beach banning open alcohol
containers
setting capacity limits and boosting
their police presence however
in florida statewide rules prevent
enforcing some sort of a mask
mandate or trying to limit capacity on
most businesses
do you really think that your
restrictions for spring break will make
a difference or is it trying to hold
back a tidal wave with a
cup listen i don't know but you got to
do what you can do we're not going to
eliminate risk we're simply going to try
to manage it with
the tools we have another tool there in
south florida
a midnight curfew beachside hotels as
you know they do rely on tourism and
after a tough year many aren't sure they
could survive
another shutdown